The joe rogan experience.
Well,
this is another thing that we talked about,
uh,
on the flight that I think is important to bring up.
Remember when there was this talk about the state monument or the National
Monument in Utah and a Patagonia put that thing on their page.
The president's stole your land.
Yeah.
Explain what actually happened because it's not what everybody thinks it is.
And Rinella said it best.
If you say the president stole your land,
you're not being accurate with your words.
That's not what happened.
It was Patagonia did an awesome marketing job I made and that there was efforts
by saying the present sold your land form.
What I've heard resulted in a 15% increase in business for them.
So it worked great.
But with the truth is,
is a lot of people felt like Obama when he,
before he left office,
did,
um,
an overreach on the national monument protection.
And so there's protecting the national monument and then,
which is a certain area he protected.
He wanted,
it encompassed 2 million acres in that national monument designation,
which seems excessive.
What Zinky says,
the secretary of Interior,
he went in there and he said,
that's an excessive,
that's an overreach.
I want to scale it back to what it was before Obama did that.
Now why is it excessive though?
This is what gets confusing to people.
People think that protecting land is never excessive,
right?
What he wants to do is make sure people have access and what,
and it's like,
okay,
so what's the difference between the Wa the way it is under Obama and the way it
is under Zinky?
It'll be Zinky scaled it back to what it was before,
which that would be,
it's still national forest,
still federal land.
But you'd be able to,
and I'm not sure if it,
if it was wilderness or how the access would be what,
but what Zinky would say is that like I would be able to go into the land all
the time if that 2 million acres,
because I might be considered by some to be elite,
you know,
because I can walk for 20 miles.
Not Everybody in the United States can walk 20 miles to get somewhere.
So they want to put road systems.
There's road systems already already but wants to maintain the roads.
So,
but if it was a national monument,
right then no road systems.
Like what is the difference that I think the road systems would be gated off and
it'd be walking and checking own foot track traffic only instead of access
through the roads.
Now why did Obama make it 2 million acres and close off the roads?
I'm not sure.
So it's still federal land.
So it's not like the government sold the land off now and no mining permits have
been issued and there's no plans to drill or anything like that?
No.
When I,
when I looked that up because I was unsure about it and I talked with Zinky
about it just because it's,
you know,
I'm learning all this as we go also.
And I was concerned when,
when I read the president's told your Atlanta,
I'm like,
what's this about?
Um,
and so,
uh,
what,
what it is,
is what he was Zinky wants to do is he wants to just make sure people have not
all abilities.
Cause it's not like we want roads on every mountain,
but have access to two national forests.
People that can drive in four by fours.
You know those little off road
on existing roads,
on existing roads and it's just like national forest now.
Natural force now has roads,
right,
right.
Designated wilderness areas because then I talked about that too.
I'm like,
well,
okay,
I understand,
I understand access.
I said,
that's great.
I want people to be able to enjoy the great outdoors also.
But I also grew up hunting the Eagle cap wilderness,
which is Oregon's largest wilderness area,
356,000 acres of no roads and I don't want roads in there.
I don't want access in the middle of the heart of that wilderness because of
some of the most pristine,
beautiful country in the lower 48 I like it like that.
So we still need to build to protect those areas.
But this wasn't in this one.
This is bears ears and and Utah.
This wasn't changing anything opening up anything or,
or this big nefarious plan of of mining and stripping everything out of the
right word.
But all it did,
it went back to what it was before.
And at that time when our research that there had been no mining permits,
that from what I understand is there is no mineral,
there's not an,
there's minerals in there,
but not enough to warrant going in there and setting up a full mineral mineral
extraction mine.
So the building,
the reason that they changed the distinction is to allow people to have more
access to that wilderness through roads that already,
right.
So windy wilderness,
it'd be national forest.
Okay.
The federal lands.
Yeah.
So
why the uproar then?
Like why is everybody so confused?
Is it a lack of communication?
Is it a lack of understanding about what the difference in the distinctions of
the two things are?
It,
it's just creating a,
you know,
a negative narrative as it's saying it's something changed,
Obama had at this way,
uh,
Zinky scaled it back.
That right there is like,
why,
what's going on?
Not really doing the research about,
he's not,
he's just putting it back to what it was because he thought that it was an
overreach by Obama.
So it's just,
you know,
these,
these outfits,
they're in business.
Um,
you know,
if everything's going good,
there's really no reason for people to get fired up and contribute money.
You know,
some of these,
some of these it's political in some respects,
businesses,
political.
Um,
it's
very cynical though.
I,
I see what you're saying,
but I think that really what's going on is people are very concerned and they
see any move,
main check concern businesses.
Yeah.
But even the businesses like Patagonia's businesses about the outdoors,
that's their whole business.
So they see anything that's a change in the Trump administration,
especially in the beginning when it came in,
people were really worried about them in terms of environmental concerns.
Right.
Because they had opened up offshore drilling.
They had done a lot of things that people were really out about.
They had opened up,
what was the area,
Jamie in Alaska where they were going to open up drilling that was near a salmon
runs that people were very,
very concerned about.
They were concerned about the idea of money above nature like,
and then me to,
right.
And who's making that money?
You're not making money.
I'm not making any of that money.
So someone else is going to make money off of what's supposed to be our land and
our public land,
which you and I could maybe go.
Even though you don't like salmon,
we could go salmon fishing in this land.
Well,
it could get fucked up by someone else making billions of dollars in oil or
natural gas or whatever the fuck we do.
If they contaminate that.
I don't want that.
No,
I don't want,
you don't want that either.
And the people from Patagonia,
So when they see something like this come up there,
red flags go up.
They want to get people outraged.
They want to get people activated because they think that they might be a chance
that if you protest enough,
you can stop something like this happening before it does.
Right.
Because if you do look at like what happened in Alaska with that big oil spill
in the 80s or what happened with the BP oil spill in the Gulf coast,
that shit's devastating.
When something like that does happen,
someone else is profiting,
making fucking billions of dollars while our,
our planet that we all share is getting fucked up.
You're not making a nickel off of it.
I'm not making a nickel off of it.
They're making billions of dollars and they're fucking up the land and by the
government,
by Trump or anybody else,
whoever's opening it up,
giving them access to drill,
right,
to do all those things,
you open up the possibility of ruining something that's amazing.
Well,
so there's always going to be a balance though.
There's,
you can't just say,
okay,
nobody can drive past this point forever.
You know what I mean?
There's always so,
but you're saying that about the Eagle cap wilderness.
You don't want them to drive past gotta be areas.
There's gotta be areas we have to protect wilderness areas,
but for example,
where we've elk hunting in Colorado,
right?
Big Bowls.
Awesome.
Elk Hunting.
There's natural gas wells all over,
right?
It's great elk hunting.
Yeah,
they've got,
so there's a valid,
they're not,
yeah,
they're not fucking it up.
So,
yeah,
I don't want things wiped out in a,
in a huge mineral extraction mine where there's used to be beautiful,
whatever,
right.
Don't want that forever.
Or is it a pollutant?
But you can't just say,
we're not doing anything anywhere.
It doesn't work.
So there can be a balance just like where are we've hunted in Colorado.
There can be a balance,
but the real concern
that the average person has me included is that someone is going to profit and
by doing that we're where it's not going to benefit you or anybody.
We know it's going to fuck it up for everybody else.
Yeah.
That's the real
concern for sure.
I know.
That's why I've tried to,
you know,
that's what I've wondered to be involved.
Like I'm on that council,
which has nothing to do with public lands in North America,
but it's given me a way to get in there and try to learn more.
That's all I'm trying to.
Well you also were involved with it when Jason Chaffetz had that proposal in
Utah to sell off
chunks of public land.
You were one of the people that sat down with him and got his take on it.
And ultimately because the outcry from people who love the outdoors and hunters
and fishermen,
that was stopped.
Yeah.
Which is very interesting.
And Jason,
uh,
he took a lot of shit,
but he seems like a very reasonable guy.
I think so too.
It's um,
you know,
he's out of politics now.
What is he doing?
He's on Fox News.
Oh,
he's a correspondent.
Yeah.
He's so,
he's completely,
he was a congressman out of Utah and I went back to DC and talk to talk to him.
That was HR six 22 and that was,
they wanted to sell what they determined disposable public land.
And I'm like,
okay,
wait a second.
Who says what's disposable?
Cause what's disposable to you?
Might not be to me.
Maybe it's a great hunting area.
So I didn't really like,
there wasn't really a way to determine what was disposable.
Right.
That's what caught my attention and other,
not just mine,
but even people like Steve Rinella in a lot of people in the loop and in the
know.
And I got advice from,
um,
let's see,
Randy Nuber,
Stever Nela,
Jill Webster at the,
uh,
Theater,
Roosevelt concert,
uh,
conservation conservation program.
All those guys are really experts in the field,
back country hunters and anglers talk to them.
I did.
People were super active about getting people to complain and protest this.
And so that one that I did get a chance to go back there and I did a podcast
with a [inaudible] and yeah,
he pulled it.
It was gone.
Never happened.
But yes,
that's,
I mean,
we just need to be educated on it and I just don't like the,
I dunno,
without that education jumping,
jumping in on the bandwagon and saying,
yeah,
the president stole my land.
It's like,
is that even true?
Well,
you know,
I always defer to Rinella when it comes to things like this because he's so well
versed in it.
So when he said that you're not being accurate with your words,
I had to look into it deeper,
but I didn't really understand it totally until I was talking to you.
And you were explaining to me the distinction between how it was before Obama
was in office.
Obama changed and then bringing it back to how it was before.
So it's still federal land.
No one sold it off.
No it's not.
It's just giving people more access to roads but amazing how when something like
that happens,
this is gigantic outcry.
Yeah.
And everybody freaks out.
It's uh,
it's confusing.
It can be confusing.
Cause I'll read two different things and I'll be like,
oh my God,
what is it this or is it that's going on?
I don't know.
Yeah.
So that's where I,
you know,
when people say,
oh well Zinky he was lying to your face.
I'm like,
ah,
I don't know maybe,
but on video,
you doubt it.
I don't,
he doesn't seem like that guy.
He,
he seems like he's a straight shooter.
You know,
I asked him about,
he was getting beat up because the national parks advisory board wouldn't,
he wouldn't meet with them.
That's what it was.
And so he got said,
you know,
Zeke,
he doesn't care national parks and he won't meet with the advisory board.
And so I asked him about that because that was in the news and that was just
like,
man,
he,
maybe he doesn't care about public land,
you know,
I mean,
I didn't know what was going on,
so I wanted to ask him about that.
And I'm like,
well,
they resigned in protest because you wouldn't meet with him.
What was that?
And he goes,
well,
yeah,
you're right.
I wouldn't meet with them.
He goes,
here's how it went.
I came in as secretary of interior and in charge of,
I don't know how many different councils,
just like the international one I'm on in this park advisory board that what
we're talking about.
And there's I think 200 and some that he's,
he really,
I think he over,
I don't even know,
thousands of employees,
billions of dollars.
And all he asked was for these advisory boards.
He wanted,
um,
a report written up that said,
what have you done in the last two years?
What are you working on now and what your goals for the next two years.
Once you provide me with that report,
then I'll get up to speed and I'll meet with you.
They never did it.
So he didn't meet with them and that was it.
That said the story was he,
he wouldn't meet with them and they resigned in protest,
but the other half of the story was he asked them to do something so he could
get up to speed and be educated on what's going on and he never supplied it.
Well,
if they are the typical government employees and what is the typical government
employee?
Incompetent.
Lazy.
I'm a government,
but typical.
Oh,
what do people think of?
They think of incompetent,
lazy,
entitled bureaucrats and they've got this job and like all of,
and he's asking them to provide,
not,
not just tell them what they've done,
but tell them what they're going to do and provide like a framework for the
future.
That makes,
that's a lot of work.
Yeah.
When someone's a lazy fuck,
if he was just kind of half ass and your job is just showing up and I'm not
saying they are,
I don't know.
I didn't know him.
Also,
they might have resented him for whatever their preconceived notions of who he
is coming into this job.
And they were,
um,
I don't know if all 12 of them,
I think there's 12.
I don't,
but I think they were all democrat.
Oh,
the son of a bitches.
So obviously he's a Republican.
He's,
he's gone unpaid volunteers.
Also unpaid unpaid volunteers.
I'm an unpaid volunteer on that council.
It's like you don't do this for money.
You do it to make a difference.
Yeah.
But if they're going to be a volunteer,
even if there are unpaid volunteer and if he asks you to have a plan,
you should probably have a plan.
Otherwise,
why have,
why are you doing it?
Because I guarantee you there's someone out there that would have a plan.
Yeah.
And especially when it comes to something that's important as national parks and
public land,
things that are like really dear and important to people.
Yeah.
This is something that,
you know,
you want to have whoever these volunteers are,
if you're going to appoint them,
you want to have the best ones for the job.
Right.
So it's asking someone to write a plan up and that's if that's
the only reasons.
He's tough because we don't have their take on it.
Well,
I've,
I read what they wrote and what did they write?
You just said that he wouldn't meet with them and whatever.
So he wouldn't read,
meet with them until they did what he asked.
They didn't say that.
He told me that,
but that's what he said.
Right.
Yeah.
Well that makes sense.
I mean,
I'm kind of in his camp,
that's if we're looking at it 100% accurately.
Yeah,
no.
And he told me face to face,
that's what happened.
So I mean,
you know,
you can say,
well,
I don't believe anybody,
I don't believe,
I don't believe what you just told me.
I don't believe that at some point you have to be like,
man,
it seemed like he was telling me the truth and I believe it.
And that makes sense.
Yeah.
It does make sense that they would not want to do that,
you know?
Yeah.
What have you been working on?
Well Chuck,
my room room going for book when I'm work,
sometimes we get pine cones.
Yeah.
So I mean,
to me he seems like hardworking,
pretty demanding.
Um,
but he cares.
I mean,
he's in there trying to,
so the secretary of interior before Zinky I had no,
I'm like,
what?
I don't even know what that is.
You know,
so that's,
that's what kind of involvement that person had in hunter,
in the lives of hunting.
People like me are fishermen.
And so when I didn't even know who it wasn't,
come to find out her name was Sally jewel who was Obama's appointee before Trump
appointed Zinky.
Um,
so I liked the fact that Zinky is at shot show.
He's had me out there.
I'm on this council is at least I have a seat at the table to say,
and I don't know,
I might get kicked off this council.
I might never get invited back because I'll ask him,
so what's going on with this?
But right now I have a seat at the table.
So whatever it's,
it's,
I,
I consider that a win.
At least I can try to find out and learn.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's an interesting thing because everything that I've heard about him that I've
read in the media,
uh,
unless I'm reading like a hunting website or something like that.
Yeah.
Everything I've heard is like that it's a horror show that he's bringing on all
these trophy hunters.
And there was an article acquainting you with being a,
a trophy hunter and that this council that he's put together is just this
disgusting sort of justification for trophy hunting and that they're only
putting it together so that wealthy people can bring back their elephants that
they shoot in Africa.
Yup.
I've read that too.
I mean,
for me,
and I'm not,
you know,
I've never killed an elephant.
I've never killed a lion,
um,
in every purse.
So even the people on the council that have,
they do care about animals,
they care.
They're volunteers just like on the parks advisory board and there they want to
make a positive difference.
You know,
I know every person on that.
I don't know every person personally,
but I know they care about the people of Africa and that's why they understand
how it works.
They've been there,
they've seen it.
Um,
the guys who I've hunted with their personally awesome people,
hardworking people.
Um,
the,
the one guy on my last trip there to Tanzania,
his daughter was in college and he'd been a professional hunter over there for
over 20 or 30 years and she was going to college now getting her degree.
I mean explain what a professional hunter over there is not what we think about
it over here.
Well we think of over here a professional hunter be a guy who hunts,
oh,
that's what it is.
Essentially a guide,
a guide.
They call him phs are professional hunters.
So I mean,
because of hunting,
he's able to send his,
his daughter to college and I mean,
and now that's gone.
Yeah.
I mean I'm not saying every person,
a lot of them.
A lot of them.
Yeah.
And there,
it's not getting any better because right now,
so that policy,
Trump said,
well,
we're going to review it on a case by case basis.
So he didn't say,
he didn't say,
okay,
it's legal now.
Everybody can hunt and and go and bring the trophies back.
He said,
we'll review each one a case by case basis.
So that still doesn't make it that good for a hunter because they say,
well,
I'm not going to book a hunt if I don't know for a fact.
I can bring my trophy back.
Yeah.
So it's not really that much better.